you don't need to be extroverted to have
success in business a lot of people
think that you need to be an extrovert
to have success as an entrepreneur and
it's totally not true
but I get where it's coming from you
know you watch sharks tank and you see
Kevin O'Leary or you look at Donald
Trump or you look at Oprah Winfrey you
see these people who are outgoing and
type-a personalities and people who
would dominate any room and you feel
like that's what I need to be in order
to be a success in my own business but
those people they're doing what they do
best right they're being on TV and in
the media because those are their
strengths and you expect them to go
all-in
and bet on their strengths well there's
tons of entrepreneurs who are behind the
scenes who aren't actually verted you
just don't hear about them who can have
success and so I don't want you to feel
like if you're not an extrovert you
won't be able to build up a successful
business this came because last week I
was doing an interview with a reporter
and she was surprised when I said that I
was in an extra word that I was very
introverted in general she's like really
but I watch your videos and I've seen
you on stage how could you be
introverted my answer was I'm just
really passionate about what I do like
that's my secret weapon my secret of
greed is that I'm really passionate and
I can turn that up when I want to but
I'm not the guy who goes to networking
events and shakes hands and hands out
business cards and if there's a roomful
of people I don't know I'm not gonna go
up and introduce myself and try to
strike up a conversation it feels
unnatural to me and so I I try to avoid
those situations and it's something that
I'm okay with and I don't want to get
better at and that's fine and I've
studied thousands of successful
entrepreneurs and what made them
successful and there's actually very
little that connects these entrepreneurs
it's not the things that you think of
it's not how actually verdure
introverted you are it's not what
country you're from or how old you are
or you know how good-looking you are if
you're a man or if you're a woman if you
have a disabilities or not it's not how
much education you have or what
religious background you come from or
how much income your parents had or how
much money you have to start up with
it's not all the things that people
usually tell themselves or the reason
that they're not successful that they
can't be successful what I found that
there's three things that bring together
the most successful people
one is that they had an idea right you
have an idea to do something I think
that's the easiest everybody has an idea
almost everybody has at least one idea
if not multiple ideas to is that they
acted on it and I think that's what
holds a lot of people back you have an
idea but you don't take any action on it
you stay in that job that you hate
working for the man working for this
company because it's a safe thing to do
because you don't have a nice
environment around you or whatever the
reason you don't actually take action on
it and that holds you back you tell
yourself a story as to why it won't work
and then number three is you don't give
up you keep going every day you take
steps and starting the business is one
of the hardest things you ever gonna do
in your life and it's gonna take
everything that you have and then some
more and a lot of people don't have the
stomach to do that and so those are the
three things that I found consistently
across every successful entrepreneur
they had an idea they took action and
they didn't give up and it has nothing
to do with all the other things that
most people think lead to success and so
no you don't need to be extroverted to
have success in business and don't try
to be focus on who you are go all-in on
you and instead of trying to be somebody
else be the best version of yourself so
my question for you guys today is I'm
curious I want to know are you
extroverted or introverted leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon